What keeps them up at night in the
positive way is the possibility that we
might contribute to the development of
human culture in a way that,
you know,
years from now,
people who will never know our names may
be able to live more empowered lives.
And you know,
if you asked like,
what is the name of your great,
great,
great grandfather,
you probably don't even know if he got
three or four greats out.
So it's not that we're mortal,
we're going to dive very,
very soon.
It's not that what we produce is going
to live on,
it will not.
But the changes that we can make in the
culture can be there for people we will
never meet.
We'll never know us.
And that's what keeps me up at night.
It's what excites me about science,
that we can learn,
uh,
ways of being with each other.
And the behavioral sciences have not
been enough of a part of cultural
development.
The physical sciences have behavioral
sciences have not.
And I would like to see if we can bring
some things into human culture that
would humanize and soften and empower
people or keeps you up at night in a
negative way is if we don't solve these
problems of the human heart and of the
human head of human psychology,
there is no technological solutions so
great that it can prevent the world that
is coming in a world of suitcase bombs
or have the ability to pollute the
planet in a way that it cannot recover a
of global warming and the rest we've
created through science and technology,
a different world that has frightening
sides to it and psychology and
behavioral science has to be part of
this because if you take something like
the so called war on terrorism by the,
if we go out another 20 years and it
doesn't just planes into buildings,
but it's a suitcase bomb in the middle
of New York,
there's not enough soldiers and there's
not enough bullets to kill enough people
to make us safe.
I think we're going to have to find a
way to humanize the culture itself and
it isn't just them.
It's us when we fly buildings,
uh,
up fly planes,
over countries,
dropping bombs on the evil ones.
I think we're doing something very
similar to what's being done when the
infidels are getting their comeuppance
with planes going into buildings.
So it's,
it's gotten to the point where if we are
not healthy psychologically as a human
society,
we will not have a planet to live on.
And that's what keeps me up at night
when I see so little focus on the
behavioral side of these problems and
the idea that just politics or,
or just science is going to solve this
or just the military.
It's not true.
We have to solve this and we've got to
solve it in our own heads and in our own
hearts,
one at a time.
And I think psychotherapy actually tells
us a little bit about what we might need
to do to soften the culture and make it
more possible for us to live together as
human beings on this planet.